how second were you when you saw people
celebrating the verdict like where
people were actually happy that would
that had to be the toughest moment I
mean you were sitting in the courtroom
when they said not guilty right yeah and
I remember just I remember I can't tell
you at the time if I remember seeing it
because I've seen so much footage you
know his family cheering and I and I get
that and Johnnie Cochran leaning over
and and you know smiling and going he
got you to you Wow Wow like he did one
of those and I just you know there was a
lot going on you know the jury was still
in there and then that's a scumbag move
yeah look he looks hurting event he
looks at you and says gotcha mm-hmm Wow
they they you know again I go I wrestled
with this for 25 years that my heart and
my mind don't always align there's lots
of times where I know logically
something makes sense but then my heart
says no I don't need it to and so this
is one of the situations where I
understand that you're entitled to a
defense you're entitled to have the best
possible defense that you can afford you
believe it and I and I and I get that he
got that I just don't have to appreciate
it like it respect it and I think that
what they did was beyond reproach and
the way that they handled themselves was
disgusting and that was kind of like the
tip of the iceberg what was it like when
when oj was putting on that glove that's
what the famous scene you were sitting
by right yeah that that was the worst
theatrical performance I've ever seen
since Naked Gun thirty-third they put
the the glove he clearly was wrestling
yeah he bent his fingers and you know
and he said he was pulling it down but
he was Napoli was like that you know he
was an actor so um you know he was
trying to pull it down but his hands
worked like a claw that was all be and
then he was talking to the jury um you
know he was talking to them which Marcia
got upset with because you know now of a
sudden if he's talking to the jury she
should be able to cross-examine him and
then he you know he does this - nothing
to see here
[Music]